Hello and welcome to this new lesson. In the last lesson, you've used objects
of classes that other people have created. In this lesson, you will learn how
to write your own classes. We'll start out with the class that models a car
that drives along. When you design a class, the first thing you ask yourself
is. What can one do with the object? Well, imagine a car object. It can drive.
Being a car, one will need to add gas once in a while. The object should be
able to tell us how many miles it has driven and also how much gas is left.
That's all that our car objects will be able to do. Now the first step is to
take this English description of the car's capabilities and turn it into the
Java code for the public interface. Her is how I like to do it. I first imagine
myself being a user of this class, so I have an object, here it's my car and
here's how I might want to call the add gas method. The name of the method,
addGas and here I'd add 20 gallons. To make the car drive, call the drive
method on the car and of course one has to say for how long to drive and here
we say 100 miles. And then I might want to find out how much gas is left in the
tank after that. So I again use the mycar object, invoke the getgasintank
method. It returns the gas level and I store that in a variable. Well, what's
the point? I now have more information. I can see that these two methods take
arguments and this one doesn't. And I can see that this method here returns a
value that's actually a number and these two don't. Now it's fairly easy to
write up the publivc interface of the class. I have four methods. Here you see
their names. You see that the first two methods have parameter variables and
you see that these two methods return values. Let's see more closely on how
this process works. Look at the add gas method here. Here, we see it takes an
argument, the number of gallons added. I've called that here the amount and
it's of type double. This method doesn't return any value, so it's declared as
a void. In contrast gas getgasintank has no argument. So there's no parameter
variable here but it returns a number. So we put the keyword double here. So
the general process when designing a class is to first informally figure out
what you want the class to do. Then to put yourselves in the shoe of the user
of the class and see how those methods might be called. And then you have
enough information to write up the public interface in Java. Sara's going to
practice that process with you with another class.